so the thing you want to watch is not
the periphery but the core that is the
critical Industries Aviation
Transportation more broadly energy
and Medicine
and there's a problem in the medical
profession for some reason medical
schools and hospitals have become
convinced that the appearance of your
doctor
is the most important thing you can
judge a book by its cover and CNN of
course is pushing and hard watch
right now fewer than six percent of
doctors in the U.S identifies black or
African-American that's despite the fact
that the community makes up 12 percent
of the country's total population and
that's raising concerns about the impact
on public health research shows that
when we have a more diverse physician
Workforce there's more understanding and
more trust between the patient and the
doctor if the doctor has an
understanding of the patient's cultural
experiences cultural background lived
experiences especially when it comes to
racism or discrimination or other
aspects of their life that can help with
that physician patient a relationship
it's super simple if there was ever a
place where we need a pure meritocracy
the most qualified people get the jobs
it's in medicine most doctors believe
that very few are willing to say it Dr
Marilyn Singleton is one of them she's
got a piece in the Washington Post
called I'm a black physician and I'm
appalled by mandated implicit bias
training and we are happy to have her
join us tonight Dr Marilyn Singleton
doctor thank you so much for coming on
why you've practiced medicine for a long
time thank you for inviting me oh well
we're delighted to have you what have
you noticed that has changed in your
profession in medicine recently and why
are you concerned about it
well I'm concerned one I grew up in a
time when there was segregation and we
moved from black people having to go to
Black universities to where it was
completely open and I was able to go to
top tier universities where my parents
didn't necessarily do that and then when
I went to medical school diversity meant
groups of different people all over the
country different backgrounds and
whatnot all we wanted to do was get good
grades and be the best doctor that we
possibly could and take the best care of
patients suddenly we fast forward now
and we don't even hear about getting
good grades all we hear about is oh a
black patient should have a black doctor
well that is so wrong a black patient
should have a good doctor and that's
what all patients want and certainly
black patients don't want that and you
believe me if you get rolled into an
emergency room you don't want a patient
having to look up at that doctor
sideways something hmm is this one of
those evil white Devils or is this a
good doctor who's going to take care of
my stab wound to the abdomen and this is
so wrong and it's being
pushed on people and I don't like the
demonization of my colleagues that I've
worked with for years save patients
lives with have them come to me for
advice on how to do something and
suddenly I'm not supposed to trust them
they're not supposed to trust me am I
suddenly a stupid black person it's it's
completely flipped on its head there was
a time when black people were considered
not up to the to the task to the job and
couldn't be professionals couldn't be
doctors and we are we're smart we're
just like anybody else and suddenly
white doctors are the ones that have the
evil Aura around them and we expect
black patients to then want to trust
that doctor and it's Holcomb that black
patient needs a black doctor number one
it could never happen there aren't
enough doctors how could you match these
people up what happens when you go go
into an emergency and I honestly as an
anesthesiologist I've done plenty of
emergencies I've been a doctor for oh I
hate to say 50 years now and patients
look at you and
yeah years ago all they wondered are you
old enough to know how to do this and
they wondered about your competence and
this is wrong having so much focus on
race and bringing back the kind of focus
that we fought for so many years to be
gone to look at people as individuals
and their talents their personality
their compassion and
they're wiping it away and it's just
wrong it's Criminal
why are you one of such a tiny minority
of practicing Physicians willing to say
that
well I think it's like so many times and
I'm sure you've been in these meetings
where everybody's thinking the same
thing but nobody wants to say it out
loud and with and part of it is what's
happening in medicine all over that we
now have private practice only 47
percent of Physicians and so you're
looking at 53 percent of Physicians are
employed or they work for one of these
big Health Systems
they're afraid they're afraid to lose
their jobs and it's kind of hard to
blame them when you're in private
practice and you're taking care of your
own patients for your own self
you know you can say what you want in
your patience when they love you they
love you and they don't care what color
you are they're just glad that you give
them good treatment
bless you for saying that I mean it
sounds obvious but when you're one of
the only people willing to say it we're
really grateful for your willingness to
do that Dr Marilyn Singleton I
appreciate it
thank you
subscribe to the fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight